in the occupied West Bank settlers deny
the daily harassment and violence
against Palestinians I think it's a very
small percentage of people if at all um
maybe in the states they hear about it
more but it's not it's not a thing that
happens it's what happens on a daily
basis Palestinian injuring Jews however
there isn't really any injury of
Palestinian by Jews so I think the
threat of the Americans is a little
disconnected from reality there is no
context no interest and it's shocking
what a shame the reality attacks caught
on camera every day even before the War
Began the United Nations said Violence
by residents of illegal settlements has
caused a mass Exodus of Palestinians
adding that since October 7th daily
settler attacks have more than doubled
the world has seen the pictures of the
dead of the homes cars and business is
burned but if the travel bans against
dozens of settlers are big news in the
occupied West Bank despite several
Administration officials briefing the
media not one mention of it in the US
Wednesday Advocate Adam Shapiro calls
the travel bands largely meaningless and
mostly symbolic but he says it is
possible the Biden Administration will
do more there's other steps such as
asset freezing um which would include
bank accounts there's looking at the
larger ecosystem of settler violence
which would include looking at the NOS
that provide charitable tax deductible
funds uh to settlements and settlement
Enterprises on the ground some may try
to deny the reality of spiraling attacks
often done in front of Israeli soldiers
but the world has seen the violence day
after day after day the question for
Advocates now will US President Joe
Biden do more to try and stop it Patty
khane Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
alzer